the attacks in Paris last November
represent a frightening new phase in
terrorism across Europe
the threat is growing as is the web of
globally connected terrorists that is
the view of the director of Europol well
I think Paris showed that Isis in
particular have decided to go global
with their strategy to take on the West
using international network of
terrorists rather than just so-called
lone actors to therefore plan and to
carry out more spectacular style attacks
a picture that I see across Europe I
think it is likely that we will have
another attack we're working of course
round the clock to to prevent that from
happening but this is a very very
serious threat the Paris attackers were
Europeans radicalized in Europe trained
in Syria the number of people who pose a
threat to us all is according to shared
European intelligence huge there's at
least 5,000 we think that have been
radicalized by Isis very often online
and have acquired conflict experience in
Syria Iraq many of them have since
returned now there are groups of these
extremists that are meeting in Europe
and of course in Syria at locations that
we can't disclose but the threat is
increasing would you would you agree
with that it's certainly the highest
terrorist threat we've faced for over 10
years and you know we need to up our
game as a collective kanda terrorist
community to make sure that we can
protect our citizens from this the trail
from the Paris attacks led to terror
cells in Belgium it exposed intelligence
failings and highlighted gaps in
European Intelligence Sharing Europol
should have plugged those gaps mr.
Wainwright
a former mi5 officer says the
organisation's cooperation with over 600
law enforcement agencies across the
continent is now better than ever
but if Britain was to leave the EU he
says it would be disadvantaged and
exposed I think it gives rise to
significant security challenges at least
in the short term and you know I'm not
certain what those alternative
arrangements could be and indeed if
there were arrangements out there that
were better than
those that the current the UK's
currently choosing to engage in the EU
and assume they would have taken them
already so what one can expect that the
arrangements will be not as optimal and
therefore it will be difficult I think
for the UK to replace what it currently
relies on in the EU with arrangements
that will be as effective and as cost
cost-efficient as well the terror threat
is evolving fast he says often shaped in
the shadows of cyberspace and global in
its reach Mark Stone Sky News in The
Hague